it's the phrase you hear these days from
dopes pretending to be smart toxic
masculinity the gist masculinity is
poison forget the great achievements
that's a great risk on the part of men
and even resulted in their deaths nope
men are violent sex bad animals and so
Brown University offers a course aimed
at unlearning toxic masculinity we used
to call this basket weaving 101 if
you're willing to give Brown 50 grand
for this crap you need to unlearn
common-sense - besides it makes no sense
I mean if men are so toxic why would you
want them detoxing on your campus
my prediction unlearning toxic
masculinity will soon be replacing
Western Civ after all there's no
question men are more aggressive than
women it's science
and it doesn't hurt to civilize unruly
cats it's what dads and moms used to do
before we decided they sucked and men do
live shorter lives just look at me but
mainly because of the risks taken to a
track to protect the people we love but
if you believe this is about
appreciating man while trimming away the
rough parts you kid yourself this is
pure class hatred based on stereotypes
meant to demean a group of people it's
the branding of a gender by angry bitter
radicals it's also sexist if you don't
believe me just create your own class
for brown and call it unlearning toxic
femininity how long do you think that'll
last well then again maybe it's in the
works already designed to focus on those
horrible toxic stay-at-home moms who
voted for Trump all right Dana let's say
you're here at brown which I believe is
a University and you would you date a
guy who is taking another okay yes you
know we do these stories about date like
remember our dating tips and you don't
that Fell's dating tips yeah
nowhere on any dating tip should you be
taking this class yeah no also I think a
better test would be for men from brown
to have to go work on a ranch
yes exactly for just for like a month
and I'm saying that as someone who
couldn't work on a ranch they would take
you though at home back home I could I
could use ray always love to have you
come - yes no it would end badly Juan
are you do you are do you filled with
toxic masculinity you feel to class I
say could I
could actually actually Pam I think I
could use the Custis it seems to me you
know the male need to be dominant and
the way that we look at sex and the
interaction I some things have puzzled
me throughout my life like for example
this is tell you one one that Jessy cuz
I just because you know you're a guide
to I just but like the OJ at the OJ
Simpson case I could never understand
why a woman would go back to a guy that
was beating her it just was puzzling to
me and then I heard from other people oh
no that's that's not unusual and I'm
like that's nuts and then my niece is a
prosecutor in DC and she tells they
people come from some countries and
they'll say oh yeah that's the way men
act men hit women I'm like what where is
that from I don't know J is what they
mean when they say toxic masculinity the
last time I was shooting the waters
world there a guy where the skirt chased
me around and heckled me I think that's
really what it is but I agree with Dana
I've always been under the assumption
that women are attracted to men that are
manly that make a lot of money that work
with their hands that sweep you off your
feet that hold the door for you take
care of you and act tough you know don't
cry never show their feelings for me Pam
do you think this is this feels like a
region camp for the for the evil mail to
me I don't know well as an employer or
as a grad school
can you imagine looking on transcripts
seeing unleashing toxic masculinity what
grade did you get if you didn't get an A
you're gonna be in big trouble taking
that class first of all this needs to be
learned obviously much younger in the
home great if you're in college and you
still have these issues you should and
not from and by the way the issues are
they just don't like me
Brown don't you think that guys sign up
for this class thinking that they're
gonna get a date yes okay
a woman who's interested in taking the
toxic math women probably want them to
take that class and then they can talk
about it and things like that but I
don't think it'll let me there but this
is now the new thing is to call it toxic
yeah that's like if you said this about
women I talked to your toxic femininity
you would be you would probably be
[ __ ] and write that article tomorrow
really I think it'll be great what would
be the symptoms dana of toxic we talk
about them all the time do we I think oh
really
geez yes geez now all right